do you remember is this I heard this is
ringing some bells our task now is to
use this on this guy and we wanted to
verify this particular result maybe we
should write that down
okay what are we trying to do we're
trying to confirm or verify that's 68%
of a population is how we say this
within one standard deviation of the
mean within one standard deviation of
the mean and I'm just going to write mu
there cuz I think where we've written
this enough that we get the sense that
that's why we use that Greek letter okay
so what would be the integral that
should if we get it right
give us 68% I'm gonna need to start
somewhere and end somewhere so where do
I start if I'm within one standard
deviation of the mean okay so one let's
let's draw ourselves a little standard a
little normal distribution here right ah
okay well that's right so right in the
middle there is zero there's at that
score negative one is off to the left
once there deviation and then positive
one is to the right is that okay so this
is going to be my boundaries negative
one to one and then I've got this as my
function so I'm gonna write that gross
one on root 2 pi e to the negative 1/2 Z
squared DZ this is what I'm after
okay now what I want to do here is I
want to look at this before I just rush
to start like putting numbers in I want
to see if I can do this any better for
example if you have a look at this shape
e the normal distribution when we were
trying to come up with this shape we
said like what characteristics does it
have it's like asymptotic but I wanted
you to remember it's symmetrical very
lightly that's the whole point of it so
when areas are symmetrical we can sort
of take advantage of that fact to make
our integrals kind of nicer see over
that think about this this is the area
I'm after here from negative 1 to 1 how
can I take advantage of symmetry to come
up with a nice integral instead of this
one
have a look at shape right yeah can I do
this in half if I do half and I love I
love zero because of how easy it is to
evaluate stuff right so if I go from
zero to one like why why I got a
negative one because it's is negatives
right that's gross if I go from zero to
one if I find that and then just double
it that should be the same do you agree
with that
so I'm gonna write that down this is
equal to two lots of the same integral
but from naught to one instead of
negative one to one
and then here's all this other stuff in
here okay at this point I'm like okay
this is better right I'm going from not
27 negative 1 1 I think I can go better
again because see this like this came
from the weirdness of the normal
distribution right but it's just it's
just a number like to Z number route to
Z number pi is a number I can just I can
factorize all these out right and then I
don't have to deal with so much inside
the integral so let's go ahead and do
that as well it's a fraction so it's
going to go over root 2 pi so far so
good and then the rest of it goes as
before ok is this is this better because
remember what I'm gonna have to do right
at some point eventually and we're
almost there I'm gonna have to put lots
of different numbers into here right I'm
gonna have to do all of this function
here function there like I don't want to
have to put in this every time I go to
the calculator so the less I have to put
in repeatedly the faster is going to be
for me okay one last step the
trapezoidal rule right I need some level
of accuracy like here I was like oh five
trapeziums or maybe two or maybe three
right I'm going to suggest that what we
pick it's a sort of a nice common number
is we go with four trapeziums so if I
suggest that we use for trapeziums you
might also hear this as four intervals
right or you might also hear it as four
applications of the trapezoidal rule
they all mean the same thing ah strings
on the ball okay so if I've got four
trapeziums right in fact I'm just going
to draw four trapeziums myself yeah
right it was like this there's another
one there's another one that'll do there
you go
for trapeziums and you can literally
count up the number of vertical lines
right 1 2 3 4 5 so 4 trapeziums means
I'm going to have to put in five numbers
up here 5 function values so I've got to
find out what they are
hmm now you get those function values
from your boundaries right so I know I'm
going to start at 0 and I'm gonna end at
1 so I need three numbers in the middle
how am I gonna get those I think I'm
gonna split it up save what are you
thinking what numbers mean you use yeah
now I'm gonna divide but what am i
dividing by again I'm just gonna point
it out up here right I'm divided by
however minami trapeziums I got I have 4
okay so this distance here is 1 so
therefore I'm going to go a quarter
every time are you okay with that I'm
just going to go ahead and write these
as decimals because we're not going to
be able to avoid decimals for very long
so 0.25 0.5 0.75 okay you good with that
you see I've got these values and I'm
getting going here okay just one last
thing before we actually just I told you
to get your calculators out before we
start country numbers you know how we
change the boundaries from negative one
to one we change it to zero to one
remember that it's nice because zero is
easy to rally there's one other good
advantage that comes from this which is
that because we're approximating over a
smaller interval we get more accuracy
does that make sense I kind of get a
trapeziums for the price of four let's
think about it right here's the area
that I've got right if I did the whole
area with four trapeziums then it would
look something like this do you agree
with that like that's that's what I
would get okay
but because I'm just focusing on this
orange part right I'm like oh I have
extra trapeziums just in this little
area here so more trapeziums equals more
accuracy okay now to the question of why
don't I just do eight in the first place
you're like I don't I'd rather do less
rather than more if I can do less and
still get better accuracy then let's go
for it
okay so what I'm going to
to do is draw up for yourself a table of
values it's gonna look something like
this it's got to be wide enough because
you're gonna have to fit in five of
these numbers in here so your top thing
is going to be a value of Zed and then
what you're going to put inside what
you're going to evaluate here is
whatever the integrand is right in this
case it's e to the negative 1/2
z squared be super careful with your
calculator and then for each value of Z
you're going to put in those numbers so
I think we said zero zero point two five
zero point five and so on
we'd better be ending at one this has
been a crunch work so I'm going to give
you some time to go ahead and do that
fill these in can you give me um give me
three decimal places I think that should
do it three decimal places and what I'd
love to see you on your page have is
this table with the right numbers in
there and then we will put them all
together into this formula okay clucky
go what have we done so far we looked at
this integral right before we left to
the trapezoidal rule we did a couple of
things to simplify it we use the
symmetry we got rid of this coefficient
out the front so things are looking good
and then we started a value said
crunching numbers right so now we can
say is this integral the one we started
with I'm now going to use the
trapezoidal which means I'm now
approximate you see that okay so I'm no
longer equal to that I'm now
approximately equals the two on square
root 2 pi it was at the front of the
integral it had nothing to do with us
crunching these numbers you never had to
type in 2 on root 2 pi or that kind of
thing right so that guy sits out the
front happily ok don't forget it's an
easy thing like we made it nice and neat
to get rid of it but you're gonna bring
it back okay and then in here wow this
looks like a lot but this is just the
trapezoidal rule do you see where my H
on to is H on - there's my 0.25 on 2 as
an added bonus and this is slightly
presentable but that to out the front
cancels was that to that we have down
the bottom so like yay less stuff I have
to do and then here come my function
values first one last
and then I double all of the middle ones
okay
now you guys have already popped down
those guys down in your table value so
I'm gonna put them onto this line here
right what have I got here
I'm not point to five on square root 2
pi he come the numbers so first one
predictably
is one because we put in a to the power
of all of the stuff times zero so you're
like cool that's easy I then skip over
all the way to the end right zero point
six oh seven there's the first and the
last one okay and then I double all the
ones in the middle so let's go ahead and
get those down I've got point nine six
nine point eight eight two and then 0.75
five by the way one of the great things
about having this table values so
logically set out is that when you have
a look at the numbers you kind of know
what you're evaluating you're evaluating
the normal distribution right well we're
valuing a scaled version of it okay so
you can see it's sort of coming down
gently question so yeah okay so this is
a good question should we use decimals
or fractions in a sense the short answer
is it doesn't matter because we're gonna
get a number out here in the end you can
see I have gone to decimals because I
knew from the function I was dealing
with I'm like gross there's not gonna be
nice neat fractions that come out of
this so I'm like forget it the advantage
of fractions is you get precision like I
can say R 4 over 7 which is exact rather
than some I don't know it's like 542
blah blah blah blah I'm like I will get
some recurring decimal here and I have
to cut it off somewhere so I'm like Oh
exact not exact right but here like
there's no way you were going to write
the fraction that like it would just be
a waste of space really so that's why
you can see I've got decimals here I
should close my big square bracket I
have been a bit messy at the front cuz
I've got a decimal on a fraction but
I'll tidy that up shortly ok do your
numbers look ok has anyone already put
into their calculator okay give me all
the decimals you get zero point
thank you I'll treat that as okay right
so we've got a number out here right
0.68 what did we set out to try and do
the answer was we were trying to verify
that 68% of the population is within a
standard deviation in 0.68 as a decimal
is also known as 68% as a percentage
right so now you know these 68 95 99
point something they didn't come out of
thin air they came from they came from
here that make sense okay question check
your calculator it is I will say like
with all these approximate methods that
the danger is it's so easy to screw up
something in your calculator